c'est un couple
ils sont à l'hôpital et la femme est
dans le lit
elle a des frères et très mal elle est
très très mal et son mari là il adore et
tout ça elle dit mon amour viens
viens il faut que je te demande quelque
chose il fait tout ce que tu veux ma
chérie tout ce que tu veux
il s'approche comme ça
une dernière fois c'est ça pas ou quoi
on est à l'hôpital tu étais avec des
perches des machins tout ça ça va pas je
t'en supplie fais-moi l'amour fais-moi
l'amour une dernière fois je t'en
supplie fais-moi l'amour
il va il prend la chaise il bloque la
porte
on y va
il va dans le lit et il commence à lui
faire l'amour ils font l'amour et elle
elle les joues qui deviennent rose elle
commence à avoir du plaisir elle est
heureuse ça se passe très très bien
c'est formidable et tout ça
quand ils ont fini elle est là elle
arrache les pères elle se lève du lit
elle fait je suis en pleine forme on
rentre à la maison et l'autre il reste
sur le lit il pleure il fait pourquoi tu
pleures pendant quand je pense que
j'aurais pu sauver ma mère
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la fait que tout le monde
déteste c'est la fée carabosh elle dit
maman c'est quoi la fée qui te ressemble
le plus c'est la fée Nantes elle dit
papa c'est quoi la fée qu'il aime le
plus bah c'est la fellation
Jean-Marie tu vois
une bouche si jolie
pardon mais c'était mon auteur ce soir
ressemblance entre une blonde et une
tortue
pourtant j'en connais beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que dit la jambe gauche et la
jambe droite d'une blonde après les
vacances on s'est pas vu depuis trois
semaines
c'est trois mecs qui meurent ils
arrivent devant l'éternel le premier il
arrive devant et l'Éternel lui dit bon
bah si on fait le point sur ta vie voilà
bravo tu as une belle femme des beaux
enfants tu as donné l'argent aux pauvres
tu as même rendu visite ton malade mais
[__] tu as une maîtresse pendant 15
ans 15 ans tiens prends cette
trottinette et vas-y casse-toi là le
deuxième il arrive et toi pareil sublime
une belle femme tes beaux enfants tu les
as élevés dans la spiritualité j'ai
entendu tes prières jusqu'ici tu m'as
prié avec dévotion bravo et [__] tu as
eu 15 maîtresses tiens prends cette
trottinette et tu te casses là le
dernier il arrive il dit toi par contre
parfait des beaux enfants tu les élever
dans les spiritualité t'a donné de
l'argent aux pauvres t'a rendu visite
malade et tu n'as jamais trompé ta femme
une seule fois tu apprends cette Ferrari
il va te balader dans les contrées du
paradis
il prend la Ferrari il se balade il se
balade à maman il se met sur le côté il
s'arrête et il pleure il pleure il
pleure là il y a les deux mecs en
trottinette ils se mettent à côté lui
mais pourquoi tu pleures il dit non j'ai
vu ma femme passer en trottinette
que j'aime beaucoup c'est un type qui
rentre dans une
église ou une synagogue on va dire une
synagogue parce que c'est plus proche de
moi et
il voit un type dans la synagogue et il
lui dit vous êtes le schémach le
schémach dans une saguette c'est comme
le bedo dans une église d'accord il fait
vous êtes le schéma je fais moi le
schéma
il fait moi le bedo tu prends pour un
con ou quoi tu veux que je te tape sur
l'épaule
c'est chaud au dessus du bedo du
shemaise et ça pardon pardon vous êtes
le rabbin
fait tu sais quoi tu vois tu regardes
bien je vais te mettre une claque je
vais démonter la tête ok je suis au
dessus du rabbin pardon pardon c'est le
rabbin de tout toute la ville
mais tu sais quoi je te parle plus à toi
tu m'intéresses pas sors d'ici sort
d'ici je vais te tuer il sert pardon je
suis au dessus de tout le rabbin de
toute la ville quoi vous êtes le rabbin
de tout le pays il fait j'en peux plus
de toi attention au dessus du rabbin de
tout le pays à la fin tu fais quoi tu es
Dieu il fait j'ai tué j'ai frappé je
vais te tuer je vais te tuer je suis au
dessus de Dieu mais monsieur au-dessus
de Dieu il y a rien voilà ce que je suis
elle est belle
ça se passe dans un bus le bus il
s'arrête là il y a un mec qui rentre il
s'installe et il regarde arabe je
regarde toujours ce sera bon dis bonjour
tu viens à la sinon elle dit maman
je suis vraiment désolé je vous ai parlé
et ben je suis Dieu
c'est pas possible grâce à ce soir
derrière arrivée derrière et ça soit il
voit un autre jeune Edith c'est un truc
de fou si je ne respecte plus rien et
souris pourquoi et un mec qui vient de
monter il m'a dit qu'il était Dieu et
l'autre il dit écoute moi j'ai envoyé
personne
[Rires]
c'est le mec qui marche dans la rue et
sans faire exprès il marche il tape dans
un carton et là il y a un génie qui sort
waouh je suis le génie du carton j'ai
l'homme tu as le droit ça existe
pas du tout
monsieur vous avez taper dans le carton
tu as droit à un venin c'est quoi ta
boisson préférée il va le le pastis du
pastis
durant chez lui d'ici il appelle chéri
chéri prépare de verre j'arrive et dis
quoi prépare de verre il arrive du
pastis tac apéro le lendemain il est au
bureau il dit attends peut-être ça
remarche du pastis chéri chéri prépare
de verre j'arrive tac tac tous les jours
prépare demain j'arrive un jour il
appelle chéri prépare un verre il a dit
je vois pas c'est ici mais ce soir tu
bois au boulot
[Applaudissements]
c'est la provincial qui vient pour la
première fois à Paris alors il se fait
la tournée de tous les monuments la Tour
Eiffel il va il va finir par la Tour
Eiffel il fait tous les autres avant
puis à la Tour Eiffel il monte au
dernier étage pour voir une dernière vue
de tout Paris il est tout seul ah non il
y a un monsieur qui est dans le coin là
il est bizarre il est comme ça il fait
53 53 53 53 il regarde il a pas l'air
bien celui-là il s'approche lui il ose
pas trop quand même 53 53 53 puis se
rapproche quand même monsieur ça va euh
oui il le prend il le jette de la Tour
Eiffel il reprend 54 55
[Applaudissements]